[Music]
dogs are one of the most lovable animals
on the planet but of course there are
some dogs who have either forgotten how
to dog completely or are just having a
momentary lapse in judgment if you love
dogs as much as we do don't forget to
subscribe and please give this video a
thumbs up today we're showing you 20
dogs who don't know how to dog the
gymnast check out the pommel horse
routine from this world-class Olympic
gymnast surely he's won several gold
medals with that form notice how his
back legs don't even touch the ground
skill and grace wait that is a dog is he
aware that dogs aren't allowed to
compete for Olympic medals in gymnastics
tree impostor the beautiful pug tree
native to Northern California is a
one-of-a-kind species of tree with only
two roots anchoring it to the ground
pug trees only Harbor three main
branches oh who are we kidding
that's a pug doing a tree imitation and
he's failing miserably at it hold on is
he practicing his handstands little baby
we're not really sure how this dog ended
up on that rocking horse perhaps their
family recently had some children the
dog might have been attempting to regain
its adorable reign as the most loveable
creature in the house who doesn't like a
dog doing people things hopefully he's
having fun with it though
catch have you ever had one of those
days you know the ones where no matter
what you do nothing ever goes right we
have a feeling that this dog is having
one of those days
he had one job playing fetch is usually
a dog's number-one skill
nevertheless this dog knows the exact
point where everything went wrong for
him oMG treats we're guessing there's a
lot that goes through a dog's mind when
he or she is presented with treats the
thought process is probably something
along the line
there's a treat look you treat tubercle
milk even cuter
try not to beg three three three this
dog probably intended to look you that
he went too far
trap oh how the Hunter has become the
hunted this dog should probably be more
embarrassed than they are the Hawks are
usually fearsome predators the last
place anyone would expect to see a dog
is in a trap meant for raccoons or feral
cats clearly he forgot he's supposed to
do the trapping instead of being trapped
himself wrong way most dogs love a good
car ride from looking out the window to
getting a Papa Chino at Starbucks
there's a lot of excitement to be had
for the car ride this dog obviously
flunked out of dog school if he only
knew how awesome car rides are maybe he
would be interested in turning around
and looking out the window definitely
human
is there something a little bit off
about this tiny human alright maybe it's
the yoga stretch that he appears to be
doing his legs are extended and wait
he's no human it appears as though this
little guy didn't forget how to dog he
simply wanted to test out being a human
neat coffee dogs can have rough days too
it's not always about chasing balls or
barking at cats and trees sometimes even
the happiest pup needs a little
pick-me-up every now and then someone
must have forgotten to tell this dog
that coffee is how humans perk
themselves up though clearly he's just
not a morning puff winning smile this is
one happy dog his adorable harness looks
safe and comfy and he's obviously
hanging out with someone he trusts
unfortunately she looks like he's too
happy to the point that he forgot how
his body works the tongue flopped out of
his mouth looks adorable but the poor
thing is clearly in the midst of a
happiness meltdown hybrid dog it appears
as though this dog is fed up with being
a dog he decided to try out being a
horse
not too shabby of an attempt by a new
horse though all he needs to do now is
find some green pastures and possibly a
few apples to munch on hopefully he
never forgets how to be a dog scared cat
dogs are known for their bravery you may
expect that big dogs will laugh in the
face of danger but even the largest dog
scared - no one told this giant dog that
he is bigger than the veterinarian it
has to be embarrassing to be carried
into the vet by her owner cat breeds
it's endearing to watch a mommy cat care
for abandoned puppies it's also
understandable when said puppies start
acting like kittens that's probably how
this dog ended up in that cat tree maybe
he just never knew how to be a dog or
maybe he loves his cat friends so much
he wants to be just like him rolled over
this Porgy is not aware of his
limitations his friend even looks a tad
bit embarrassed as he stares at someone
off camera the other dog won't even look
at him
what happened did his friends shove him
off the sidewalk who's that kerb just
too tall for his short little legs
it's okay Corgi you certainly tried
frisbee fail it's difficult to imagine a
dog that doesn't like to play fetch in
one way or another so it has to be
embarrassing as a dog to fail at
catching anything even worse is when
someone captures that fail on camera
hopefully this poor dog leveled up on
his catching skills and hasn't missed
since hover dog that's not a dog that's
a UFO that somehow got stuck in
someone's house it's a genius design
though if it weren't floating in mid-air
humans would mistake it for a dog the
UFO has plenty of fur for legs a tail
and fuzzy ears if it's a dog it's
obviously not a very good one new pillow
this is the newest model of couch all
right so we're not fooling anyone that
is quite obviously a dog that failed big
time we're wondering if he enjoys
sleeping in between couch cushions while
upside down maybe he was sleeping on top
of the cushions and slid down in between
them hopefully his owners noticed before
sitting down
backflip that's not a dog it's a
meteorite falling from the sky dog
simply do not fall headfirst from above
how would he even get in that position
in the first place he's just floating
there in midair wait he does look kind
of annoyed with his predicament maybe
he's just really excited about the
prospect of building a snowman - toy
dogs love chewing on anything they can
get their paws on it's part of their
nature they don't always chew on the
right toys though this pup has found an
interesting
you chew toy we're not sure that he
knows that's his own leg or not he
doesn't look like he's biting down too
hard though so maybe he's just goofing
around
attack dog it's pretty much a given that
dogs do not like cats dogs can easily
hold their own against a tiny kitty cat
right we think this dog forgot that he's
a dog and therefore much larger than a
little kittens you would think that he'd
be the one chasing the kittens but
instead the kitten has a nice hold on
him and that's it for 20 dogs who don't
know how to dog if you liked this video
be sure to hit that like button and
subscribe for more great content from
the things thanks for watching and see
you next time
[Music]